>>James: I became Principal
of Visitacion Valley Middle
School in the Fall of 1999.
My first day here I heard noise
outside, I looked out my window,
and there were two students tearing
the gate off the hinges to get
into the yard to play basketball.
When I got out to the yard, I noticed
there were some young students
playing cops and robbers.
I walked up to the young
man, and I said, "Hey,
can I look at that for a minute?"
And he said, "Sure," and he
handed me his father's .45.
>>James: In the 2002/2003
school year,
we had 41 murders occur
in this neighborhood.
And the students at this school,
either were related to the persons
who did the shooting, who
were shot, or were present
when the shooting took place.
So there was a tremendous
amount of stress, and anxiety
and fear for the students.
>>Laurent: The stress
levels were so high
that everyone was really
functioning at a disadvantage
as a result of the environment.
And it was impacting their
psychological well-being.
And many of the students actually
have not only ADHD, but PTSD.
>>Carlos: You take a ride down
any barrio or ghetto in America,
and you hear the boom boxes.
You hear the shouting.
And unfortunately, too many
of our kids even hear gunfire.
>>James: I think that many urban
schools today are run like jails,
because the kids are out of control.
And that's because of the
environment they live in.
We're not running a jail here.
We're running a school.
>>Laurent: The research is showing
that stress is a major problem
in our educational system.
We can't have an effective
educational system
if we don't address
the problem of stress.
This impacts our neurophysiological
functioning.
>>James: In order for kids
to learn and be creative,
they have to feel happy and safe.
So I needed to start working on
the social/emotional end of things.
And I heard about Quiet Time.
And we took a brave step
forward into a new world
of teaching our students
how to meditate.
>>Teacher: Head up, eyes closed.
Quiet Time starts now.
>>Noah: Quiet Time is the
first activity of the day,
when the students arrive.
And it's also the last activity of
the day, before they're dismissed.
>>Announcement: Please
excuse this interruption.
Please begin your Quiet Time.
Thank you.
>>Noah: The teacher rings a bell, and
that starts the Quiet Time session.
There's a 12-minute time period from
when the teacher rings the first bell
until the teacher rings
the second bell.
It's really completely
silent in the room.
The students are meditating.
>>Man: How many people
here meditated?
Raise your hand.
>>Jocelyn: I'm Jocelyn.
I am an eighth grader at
Visitacion Valley Middle School.
I live on Sunnydale.
There was a day where
there were people walking,
and then my dad heard gunshots.
Like I felt like I couldn't move.
The meditation helped me.
It was like a force that
blocked what I just experienced.
>>Rose: We're giving
kids a coping mechanism.
The problems that you have keep
coming, except your ability
to deal with them changes.
Behaviorally, you see a difference.
Especially, I definitely saw a
correlation between their behavior
and being more manageable in class
after they started meditating.
>>Carlos: If we continue to do what
we've always done, we're always going
to get what we always got.
Is that good enough?
I don't think it's good
enough for the 21st Century.
We need to be the outliers
to try things
that have never been
tried, and see if they work.
In education, our job
is to touch the future.